raison que je vais m'assurer que peuvent
faire un peu plus de 5000 militaires
français à l'efficacité certes reconnu
sur une zone aussi vaste même renforcé
par cinq mille soldats pour lui par les
pays vieux 500 c'est là où les problèmes
ont commencé
les déclarations récentes des politiques
des spécialistes des experts des
militaires montre bien que nous sommes
face à une incompréhension totale entre
les différents acteurs
si la france n'a pas la volonté
nécessaire pour assurer la réalisation
de ses objectifs et de les accompagner
par qu'il ne s'agit pas d'imposer il
s'agit de convaincre et d'accompagner il
est à craindre que nous terminions
enlisé dans un conflit sans fin
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt france
du lundi au jeudi on se retrouve pour
1h30 d'émission nous décrypterons comme
chaque soir l'essentiel de l'information
voici les titres de l'actualité les
conditions d'un défend finement à partir
du 11 mai sont elles réunies les
incertitudes demeurent au lendemain de
la conférence de presse d'edouard
philippe il s'agit du début d'une
nouvelle phase avec des précautions
sanitaires toujours de mise et à
respecter pendant plusieurs mois
les restaurateurs français eux
s'estiment en danger de mort et dix sept
grands chefs en appelle au président de
la république nous serons en direct avec
l'un d'entre eux yannick alléno
[Musique]
un autre coup de colère celui des
syndicats agricoles qui appellent à la
grève des animaux si la consommation a
de viande augmente à la faveur du
confinement le prix payé aux
agriculteurs par les industriels et la
grande distribution lui diminue d'où cet
appel aux éleveurs de garder leurs
animaux à la ferme et de ne pas les
vendre tant que leur situation est en
péril un premier déconfinement ce lundi
en norvège et en allemagne où les
magasins d'une surface inférieure à 800
mètres carrés ont pu rouvrir
mais les allemands ont devons être
disciplinés prévient guélat merkel en
italie le nombre de malades baisse pour
la première fois
[Musique]
en france la tension ne redescend pas du
côté de villeneuve la garenne dans les
hauts de seine
les échauffourées ont à nouveau éclaté
la nuit dernière quatre individus ont
été interpellés a sonné après l'accident
de moto impliquant une voiture de police
deux versions s'opposent aujourd'hui
entre forces de l'ordre et témoins dans
la nuit plusieurs autres communes de la
région ont connu des heures
[Musique]
la france franchit donc un cap
symbolique et douloureux déplore plus de
vingt mille décès annoncent du directeur
général de la santé jérôme selle au mans
il y à quelques minutes qui explique que
chaque personne malade contaminé
contamine moins d'une personne autour
d'elle contre trois au début de
l'épidémie ce qui veut dire que la phase
de freinage est bien avancé le nombre de
décès à l'hôpital et 247 en 24 heures
écoutées en france selon les estimations
de santé publique france 114 1657 cas
serait confirmée ce soir les remontées
de 1291 établissements de santé publics
et privés font état de 30 mille 584
personnes encore hospitalisées pour la
prise en charge d'une infection qu'ovide
dix neuf mille quatre cent soixante cinq
nouveaux cas ont été admis ces dernières
24 heures à l'hôpital
en tenant compte des sorties le solde
est négatif mais très faiblement avec 26
personnes hospitalisées en moins par
rapport à hier
nous surveillons de très près la
situation de nos aînés et en particulier
un particulier la situation dans les
établissements sociaux et médico sociaux
depuis le début de le début de
l'épidémie nous avons 64 1394 cas dont
23 1668 confirmée par test pcr au sein
de 5741 établissements sociaux et médico
sociaux qui ont déclaré des cas et donc
participer à cette remontée nationale
d'information en ce qui concerne la
mortalité
ce soir notre pays franchit un cap
symbolique est particulièrement
douloureux et déplore plus de vingt
mille décès est l'une des clés
incontournable du confinement les tests
le gouvernement espère également au réel
les 500 milles thèse par semaine à
partir du 11 mai à marseille on n'a pas
attendu des centres de dépistage se met
en place un médecin sans frontières
lance un appel à l'état objectif rendre
possible la mise en quarantaine des
personnes testées positives pour le
moment aucune réponse des pouvoirs
publics c'est ce qu'expliquent les
cadres des messes foyer j'ai contacté
une société de mobil-home ya aussi des
centres des vacances aujourd'hui ne
fonctionne pas il ya des centres de
tourisme qui aujourd'hui ne fonctionne
pas des auberges de jeunesse qui ne
fonctionne pas et je crois que eux soit
pour mettre pour confiner des personnes
soit il ya deux possibilités soit on
sort de l'habitat la personne qui est
qu'ovide positif soit on sort de
l'habitat les personnes vulnérables qui
sont elles celles et qu'on aurait la
possibilité de faire sortir on amène
plusieurs réunions à notre niveau et en
a discuté de placer ces gens au niveau
d'automne quitte à nous mêmes faits
lancé lors leur isolement
donc à défaut que les pouvoirs publics
prennent les devants et qui font cette
démarche pour toute la population
et pour évoquer cette crise du
coronavirus la stratégie de
déconfinement nous sommes avec jérôme
marty médecin et président du syndicat
des médecins de l'union française pour
une médecine libre bonsoir j'ai remarqué
merci d'être avec nous on vient de le
voir l'exemple marié ou honte est
davantage que dans le reste du pays
vous saluer cette initiative c'est ce
qu'il faudrait peut-être ailleurs en
france
tester tester tester c'est ce que yves
oms
c'est ce qu'il faut faire effectivement
mais on doit encore honorer un retard
qui est très important on a un retard en
termes de moyens de protection les
masses que les surblouse l'ailé
surchaussures les écrans de protection
il a fallu que ce soit des entreprises
qui les fabriquent des entrées des
imprimantes 3d on n'a toujours pas
véritablement de moyens et puis les
tests on est très en retard alors le
gouvernement la boutique que l'on va
être en capacité de faire 500 me le test
par semaine on a envie de le croire
malheureusement le passé a montré que
chaque fois qu'on a voulu donner en
quelque sorte une date butoir elle a été
très largement dépassé ce qui est
certain c'est que ce virus va faire
partie de nos vies pendant encore des
mois et des mois et des mois
on rappelle qu'il y avait à 10% de la
population à peine qui est immunisée que
l'on n'a pas de traitement que l'on n'a
pas de vaccin que l'on un peu de tests
et que l'on a peu de masques donc par
rapport à ça il ne reste plus que les
gestes barrière il ne reste plus que le
civisme de chacun d'entre nous pour
arriver à continuer à maintenir cette
épidémie en deçà de nos capacités de
prise en charge et faire que la courbe
continue à se casser je rappelle que
pour l'instant on est sur un plateau
avec des oscillations que le nombre de
morts est très sous-évalué il faut le
répéter à l'envi parce que monsieur
sanogo nous donne toujours une vision
très parcellaire
il ne compte et ne comptabilise que les
décès à l'hôpital et fort heureusement
maintenant enfin fort heureusement si on
peut dire maintenant les décès également
en ehpad à l'établissement médico
sociaux et toujours rien sur la ville
toujours rivé sur les domiciles toujours
rien sur la précarité sur la solitude
etc
j'ai remarqué justement concernant ces
tests vous l'avez dit l'objectif est de
500 mille tests edouard philippe l'a
fait comprendre ça va être l'une des
clés de cette stratégie de déconfinement
mais il n'arrive pas un peu tard parce
qu'on rappelle cette grande différence
majeure c'est est ce sont des tests pcr
qui permettent de savoir si oui ou non
on a le virus dans l'instant mais ce ne
sont pas des tests de sérologie qui
permettent de savoir si on est oui ou
non immunisés donc c'est pas vraiment
trop tard justement de tester les
personnes qui se sont confinés qui a
priori ne rompt pas le virus
non c'est pas trop tard parce qu'encore
une fois il ya que 10% la population qui
est immunisée donc le virus par
circulaire
vous savez que le confinement et c'est
ni plus ni moins posé une cloche sur les
incendies l'étouffer mêlée samedi est
toujours en vie et quand on va relever
la cloche le risque c'est que cela
reprenne cela reprenne par contact
proche et prolongé entre chacun d'entre
nous et que l'épidémie se diffuse à
partir de là il faut qu'on soit en
capacité ce tir le gouvernement l'audit
tester les gens c'est automatique on
rappelle qu'il y a une immense
proportion de cas asymptomatiques il
faut certainement certainement visé en
tout cas ce que les plus grands se
montre nous que les plus grande
interaction sociale c'est à dire ce
qu'il voit le plus de monde et cela il
faut bien les tester de façon aléatoire
contrairement à ce que dit le ministre
et je m'inscris en faux
il y à des pays qui ont fait des tests
aléatoires c'est la corée du sud c'est
immoral c'est l'islande
il ya des pays qui vont le faire c'est
la suède et le québec on est très loin
du discours de monsieur virement autre
clé du déconfinement les masses car là
aussi on a fait des petits à les
retourner masque obligatoire
dans les transports on en parle beaucoup
mais pas forcément à l'école la réaction
du médecin l'action du métier c'est que
la même que celle que je tienne depuis
des semaines mais bécaud et soeurs et
mes confrères aussi le masque c'est pas
un complément comme a pu le dire là
aussi le ministre c'est pas un
complément aux gestes barrières
récepteur c'est quelque chose
d'indispensable
et j'insiste bien là dessus c'est
indispensable
chaque fois que la distanciation social
au physique doit être rompu dans les
transports en commun notamment vous
devez tous porter des masques parce que
vous êtes tous potentiellement porteurs
asymptomatiques vous pouvez donc
contaminer les gens qui sont autour de
vous le masque est un masque écran c'est
fait pour protéger votre entourage et
donc vous devez bien évidemment le
porter quand edouard philippe dit il
faudra s'habituer on va vivre encore
longtemps avec ce virus alors que
s'amorce une stratégie de déconfinement
on est plutôt en retard en france
vous est-ce que vous restez néanmoins
optimiste éventuellement sur une
disparition du virus on entendait le
professeur raoul dire que ce virus
cette épidémie pourrait disparaître au
printemps est ce que il ya un espoir
goûtez moi j'ai pas de boule de cristal
que ce que je regarde ce sont à la fois
les chiffres ce sont les retards ce sont
les manquements
oui oui bien sûr il ya l'espoir oui on
va arriver à dominer cette pathologie de
toute façon il y aura un vaccin
on va aussi découvrir des traitements on
en apprend tous les jours mais en
attendant en attendant il va être là
pendant des mois et je pense aujourd'hui
effectivement aux restaurateurs vous
avez parlé yannick alléno qui sera avec
vous sur cette chaîne thaler
on ne peut commencer à ou aux autres et
aux ateliers qui ne peuvent pas réouvrir
qui ont des situation financière
catastrophique qu'il va falloir aider et
là aussi si on avait eu les moyens
si on avait eu les moyens de protection
suffisamment tôt si on avait eu les
tests suffisamment tôt on n'en serait
peut-être pas là aujourd'hui en corée
serait plus avancées dans la lutte
contre cette épidémie qu'on ne l'est
aujourd'hui
et puis je pense aussi juste dans
quelques mots je pense aussi à l'état
des cabinets des médecins de ville des
kabyles et des soignants libéraux qui
aujourd'hui ont d'une perte financière
qui est immense qui risque de précipiter
leur cabinet daver la fermeture parce
que il ya eu des mots malheureux là
encore de la part de ceux qui nous
gouvernent qui ont appelé les patients à
ne pas aller trouver dans médecin
généraliste ou alors juste un extrême
urgence et ses patients ont coupé les
ponts ce qu'a fait non seulement prendre
des risques à ses patients mais qui en
plus qui en plus a menacé directement la
pérennité économique de ces cabinets qui
si on ne les aide pas ils vont s'ajouter
à voir ce qu'en disent les déserts
médicaux
on sent très rapidement jérôme article
sur ce point le le gouvernement
rétropédale un olivier ferrand vraiment
appeler les français à les consulter
pour d'autres symptômes d'autres
maladie ça récupère peut-être un petit
peu les choses à vos yeux
non ça récupère toi pourquoi je vais
vous dire pourquoi depuis le début on a
oublié qu'il existait une médecine de
ville et quand je dis médecine entendre
pharmacienne entendre infirmières aides
soignantes auxiliaires de vie qu'il
existe un tissu sanitaire de ville ce
tissu sanitaire s'occupe de 95% des
patients qu'au budget insiste bien sur
ce chiffre quatre-vingt-quinze pour cent
ce tissu sanitaire a été présente depuis
le début la majorité des gens qui sont
tombés chez les médecins qui sont
décédés malheureusement saône des
libéraux personne n'en parle
personne fait dommage est profession à
cette part de la profession
on a des hommages pour les hospitaliers
je les salue on a et on a vu des
artistes qui font des chansons sur
l'hôpital on a un grand quotidien qui
aujourd'hui offre gratuitement aux
membres de l'hôpital
on a des défauts rôti lève des fonds qui
lève de l'argent pour l'hopital
encore une fois je salue je sais quel
est le métier là et la dureté pour
rencontrer nos confrères soeur et le
beau frère hospitalier mais quand même
de grassois de grâce
on n'oublie pas que j'existe médecine de
ville merci beaucoup jérôme marty
médecin et président du syndicat de
médecins de l'union française pour une
médecine libre merci d'avoir été avec
mon sur rt france est parmi les rôles
essentiels on s'étend de confinement
celui des travailleurs portuaires au
havre par exemple ils travaillent jour
et nuit pour ravitailler le pays des
salariés qui ont malgré tout tenu malgré
tout dû adopter de nouvelles méthodes de
travail pour assurer leur sécurité
reportage sur place de pierre pissavy
yvernault avec jordi demory c'est une
journée plus que banale sur le port du
havre est les chariots cavaliers ces
grandes machines déplaçant les
conteneurs travaillent 24 heures sur 24
le but réapprovisionner les magasins de
première nécessité partout en france un
rôle essentiel pour la vie du pays en
ces temps de crise sanitaire n'a essayé
abandonné nationalement au tour de la
fédération nationale des ports et docks
de
demandez est ce que le gouvernement
priorise les activités essentielles et
donc les produits de première nécessité
ça c'est pas trop trop mal structuré et
donc on arrive à acheminer acheminer des
denrées de première nécessité et les
faire les faire véhiculer vers tous les
points d'approvisionnement du pays
premier port de france en volume de
marchandises à des milliers de dockers
et travailleurs portuaires viennent ici
travailler tous les jours mais depuis le
13 mars dernier leurs conditions de
travail ont dû s'adapter aux règles de
sécurité
ici pas question d'y déroger on essaie
que tout le monde soit équipé alors ça a
été compliqué parce que évidemment il ya
une rupture de stock au niveau national
donc elle a fallu bassiste mdl et se
voir dans les pharmacies qui pouvait
produire du gel hydroalcoolique donc
après c'était trouver d'autres moyens
pour des la désinfection donc nous on
avait trouvé des choses basiques comme
de l'eau avec de la javel et des
pulvérisateurs désinfecté au début du
shift et à la fin du shift pour
justement que le poste reste le moins
contaminés possible donc après ouais
c'est le système d c'est
essayez de apprendra aussi un lien c'est
le correspondant sécurité chaque service
à un correspondant sécurité
est ce cette personne là est un peu le
garant de la sortie de stocks au niveau
du magasin pour pour approvisionner les
gens qui sont dans le désert et pour
tenter de travailler en toute sécurité
les salariés se sont organisés
distribution de kits de masques
nettoyage régulier des postes de travail
face à la pénurie de gel hydroalcoolique
les salariés du port du havre ont aussi
trouvé la solution
alors au niveau du gel les camarades
dockers au niveau de son de formation
une machine qui fabrique le carrément la
le gel
donc ça aujourd'hui aucun souci même
dans les cavaliers vous pas regardé il
ya du matériel et à tous au niveau des
sous quand il ya aucun problème aussi là
dessus c'est surtout un petit point le
price au niveau des masques mais
aujourd'hui on va dire ça ça s'arrange
sachant qu'on a aussi adapté aux
démasqué tissu pour des gens qui sont
pas dans les premières approches c'est
donc une ville dans la ville qui fournit
jour et nuit qui contribuent elles aussi
à l'effort national bateau train camion
ce sont plusieurs tonnes de marchandises
qui quittent chaque jour le port du
havre à destination des quatre coins du
pays et le monde de la gastronomie tape
à son tour du prince charles est à 17
chefs appelle le président de la
république à l'aide
il tend ainsi à leur tour de venir en
aide aux restaurateurs victimes du
confinement l'ombre d'entre eux
cherchent des solutions alternatives
pour ouvrir certains devront mettre la
clé sous la porte a bordeaux les
quelques restaurateurs présents dans
leur établissement le son pour nettoyer
ou aménager une alternative de service
écoutez ces témoignages
né en attente finalement des décisions
du gouvernement puisque on attend un
éventuel déconfinement 11 mais qui n'est
pas réellement
sur toutefois on espère quand même une
ouverture dans l'été éventuellement en
proposant une carte réduite et puis fait
un petit peu de tyco et puisque
puisqu'on est loin de connaissances à
savoir si on ouvrira réellement dans
l'été et sous quelles conditions
en vain
réouvrir en format épicerie et
restauration à emporter plats cuisinés
et produits crus aussi puisque en étant
restaurateurs bien sûr on a les
approvisionnements on peut les avoir on
allait des légumes comme avant de la
région on a toutes les volailles de la
région les a aussi on a tout ce qu'il
faut
donc on peut cuisiner donc on va
cuisiner des plats cuisinés et on va
vendre aussi des produits bruts légumes
les fraises les asperges de blaye faut
adapter notre restauration maintenant
donc on s'organise on cherche et
fournisseurs de nouveaux fournisseurs
qu'on adapte notre restaurant et on
on se fait connaître d'une autre façon
on essaie de penser à des plats qu'ils
puissent s envoyer à la fois qui change
qui puisse permettre aux gens du
quartier de manger des plats variés sans
être trop cher et qui soit aussi bon à
l'envoi qu'une fois à la maison et pour
en parler nous sommes avec le chef
yannick alléno chef triplement étoilé à
la tête de 18 établissements dans le
monde dont le doyen à paris bon soir
yannick alléno merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt font partie
des signataires de cette tribune parue
chez nos confrères du figaro
que demandez-vous précisément emmanuel
macron alors ne demandez rien au
président on propose on propose au
président c'est à dire que je pense que
le temps est venu de dar été de réclamer
et de se prendre en main je pense que le
et nous pensons d'ailleurs que la
restauration peut s'organiser pour
commencer à accueillir le public dans
des règles de sécurité et pour notre
personnel et pour le des clients optimum
donc ça veut dire qu'il faut que l'on
réfléchisse nos espaces autrement nos
nounous procédures d'accueil et de
remettre gentiment la vie en route parce
que dépend de nous plein de fournisseurs
plein de producteurs des vignerons et
tout et on n'a pas envie d'attendre que
le gouvernement nous dise badr démarré
au mois de septembre au mois d'octobre
j'en sais rien
donc on a envie de proposer de faire de
faire en sorte de restaurants revivent
petit à petit aux réunions de questions
de réouvrir 100% c'est sûr mais en tout
cas que les flammèches de nos fourneaux
commença à est un seul est alors vous
avez justement pour cela envoyer
plusieurs solutions
hier soir au gouvernement pour permettre
cette réouverture
expliquez-nous un petit peu parce que
c'est vrai qu'on a du mal à imaginer la
compatibilité entre cette distanciation
sociale les gestes barrières et
l'activité
restaurant nécessairement il ya
forcément du contact bien sûr alors pour
vous et pour vous donner un exemple j'ai
un restaurant en corée ce qui m'aide
aujourd'hui à comprendre comment les
choses ont évolué dans des pays qui
réagit différemment et encore et on a
mis tout un protocole nouveau en place
pour accueillir les clients et on a
commencé à faire trois couverts
aujourd'hui on en sait 110 par jour donc
ça fonctionne plutôt pas mal donc on a
mis en place et je sais tout n'est pas
applicable au restaurant certains ont
des solutions et d'autres d'autres
solutions mais en tout cas je vous
explique ce que nous avons mis en place
en corée à l'aide du gouvernement coréen
des tapis de désinfection c'est à dire
que client arrive il a déjà fait 4
mètres et ses chaussures ont été
désinfectés des boîtes à usage unique ou
dans lequel le client mais son masque
pour aller à table un sas de d2 je
dirais de désinfection de ses mains les
manteaux sont mis sous des films
plastiques de que l'on peut trouver
d'ailleurs dans les pressings a cédé
même chose et ensuite les le personnel
aux contacts portent des masques et des
gants et en cuisine nous portons des
visières des toques des gants il ya des
postes des infections à m 2 un maître du
temps qui fait le tour des cuisiniers
pour le pour leur rappeler les bons
gestes des bons gestes barrières mais
vous savez en cuisine on a quand même
l'habitude de cette rigueur puisque
depuis tout le temps désinfectant
cuisine depuis tout le temps des uns
fait mieux depuis tout temps on se lave
les mains et l'hygiène est quelque chose
de éminemment déjà ancrée donc il faut
aller plus loin dans ses démarches et de
et on va essayer d'écrire un livre ait
de bonnes pratiques pour commencer à
prouver au gouvernement que nous sommes
capables d'accueillir du public dans de
bonnes conditions et je pense que c'est
important
yannick heulot pardonnez moi parce que
le temps passe malheureusement il ya 17
chefs très prestigieux qui ont signé
cette tribune pour la plupart qui ont ce
qu'on appelle des grands restaurants
mais vous vous exprimez vous y tenez au
nom aussi des autres restaurateurs vont
peut-être plus modestes est ce que cette
stratégie vous semble
mise à part dont applicable pardon à des
restaurants peut-être plus modestes mais
bien sûr je pense que on se le rappeler
tout à l'heure avec alain ducasse
il y aura les bons il y aura les mauvais
les bons doivent qu'il soit petit grand
immense étoilé pas étoiles et appliqués
en fonction de l'heure de leur capacité
l'accueil des clients
il y avait stéphane jégo qui a son
bistrot l'ami jean avec nous il est
d'accord avec tout cela je veux dire il
est hors de question de dire qu'il ya
des grands qui ouvrait les petits qui
reste car mais c'est impossible
d'imaginer ça en attendant chacun qui
décide d'ouvrir doit être responsable de
cette qualité hygiène et de sécurité de
des clients et du staff
s'il ne peut pas le faire écouter il
faudra attendre un petit peu que les
choses s'améliorent mais je pense qu'il
ya beaucoup beaucoup d'établissements il
ya 120 mille ou cent 4,1 milliards
établissements en france qui seront
capables d'ouvrir gentiment à la
clientèle et qui sont je le rappelle
tous des restaurants de qualité au
collège culinaire de france et d et des
gens qui ont l'habitude de faire
attention à tous les détails
il ya vraiment danger de mort pour
plusieurs restaurants parmi justement
ces 17 chefs selon vous réellement mais
bien sûr il va falloir parler d'eux des
loyers il va falloir parler des
assurances subir dès qu'elle est les
choses c'est m on le disait le docteur
17h le mettre sous cloche les trucs
desquels et les choses c'est mais c'est
mettre sous cloche un problème il ya des
établissements avec avec très peu de
trésorerie qui sont déjà en train de se
poser la question de te reo pas on pense
que si on ne fait rien et que je vais
pas les choses de 304 40% des
établissements ferment qui sont partis
effectivement des fleurons de la
gastronomie française merci à vous et
yannick
elle est notre chef triplement étoilé
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur
erquy et fronde remercie est la question
centrale que l'on se pose on en a parlé
depuis le début de ce journal at-on le
moyen d'un déconfinement si la date du
11 mai dans tous les esprits elle est
aussi l objet de toutes les inquiétudes
est de tous les doutes tentons jugés
trop proches 30 ans jugée trop tardive
les conditions d'un déconfinement à
partir du 11 mai seront elles bien
réunis c'est l'objet de notre face à
face et pour en débattre nous sommes en
direct par skype avec benjamin amar
enseignants en porte parole cgt
val-de-marne bonsoir benjamin amarres
avant mon côté en face à philippe
merlant economics essayiste bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous aussi à distance
philippe herlin dans quinze jours le
grand plan un suspense que tout le monde
attend sera dévoilé vous y croyez
benjamin on vous a déjà entendu pousser
des coups de gueule sur ce plateau vous
l'attendez avec fébrilité ce plan du
gouvernement
ah non vous savez un cégétiste s'est
jamais fébrile non moi je vais vous dire
je moi je suis quelqu'un qui résonne
simplement moi ce que j'attends ce qui
est pour moi la condition sinequanone de
cette histoire de déconfinement c'est
les conditions de sécurité sanitaire
voilà les masques les masques notamment
on le sait très bien on nous a dit le
gouvernement nous a seriné pendant des
mois en dix ans dans ce qui était un
mensonge éhonté
il n'y a pas besoin des masques ça ne
sert à rien on sait aujourd'hui que
c'est totalement faux que c'est porter
un masque setra gestes barrières
extrêmement efficace donc se pose cette
question là c'est à dire que l'urgence
économique moi je la comprends et je la
partage
bien évidemment que l'économie ne peut
pas rester au point mort ainsi pendant
des mois quoique reconnaissons qu'il ya
beaucoup de secteurs de l'économie qui
continue à tourner et des secteurs qui
ne sont pas essentiels mais mais pour
autant le fait que l'on reprenne une
activité économique normale bien
évidemment mais comme l'a dit philippe
martinez par la peur au ventre
il faut effectivement des séquelles la
première des exigences c'est la vie des
gens c'est tout simplement le fait que
les gens
risquent pas leur peau voilà et donc
cette question là moi j'ai écouté le
gouvernement
la conférence de presse de monsieur
philippe et c'est encore le flux tôt la
bombarde et le pipeau parce que
finalement depuis des mois les masques
arrive
écoutez on les attend comme le messie
donc c c'est tout simplement ridicule et
je pense que c'est la question
essentielle si on a effectivement des
conditions de sécurité sanitaire le
déconfinement pourra se faire
sereinement
si ça n'est pas le cas on n'en verra pas
les gens au casse-pipe
philippe herlin on envoie les gens au
casse pipe c'est clairement la crainte
de benjamin masque c'est la vôtre
également oui c'est possible par une
passante lac à la politique du
gouvernement et est dirigée par la
pénurie alors que moi je considère que
le 11 mai est une date qui est bien trop
tardive
il faut savoir que la france est le
dernier pays en europe à des confiné et
ça veut dire que nous allons prendre un
retard sur tous les autres concurrents
européens
et ça veut dire aussi que de nombreuses
entreprises françaises vont encore
failli et tout à l'heure le chef alléno
parler des 40 % des restaurants qui ne
regroupe pourrait par ouvrir
éventuellement après le confinement 40%
aux failles et ce sont des centaines des
milliers d'emplois et est donc pas je
considère qu'il est plus urgent d'ouvrir
les entreprises que les écoles parce que
le problème des écoles c'est que comme
on a affaire à des enfants
il y pense forcément facile de faire
respecter les règles de distanciation
sociale alors qu'avec les commerces les
restaurants les coiffeurs les fleuristes
et cetera
on a affaire à des adultes donc il est
quand même plus simple de faire
respecter les règles de distanciation
social les gens font la queue à
l'extérieur et c est donc pour moi il
faudrait faire mettre la priorité sur
les entreprises et avant le 11 mai et
les écoles
ensuite une fois qu'on aura pu mesurer
qu'il n'y a pas de retour de l'épidémie
en france sans sauf qu'il ya peut-être
un petit problème pratique c'est que en
général quand on a des enfants à la
maison c'est un petit peu compliqué de
se rendre au travail n'est ce pas ce que
c'est ça peut-être l'arrière pensée -
yamaha m'a pas bien évidemment bien
évidemment enfin personne ne peut être
naïve dans cette histoire on le sait
très bien
moi j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le lire
alors vous savez le le medef c'est
l'acteur furtif de la vie politique
française c'est à dire que si on
personne n'en parle mais il est là il
est bien là croyez le bien
et donc le
il fait le patronat ses pressions sur le
gouvernement et vous l'avez très bien
résumé pour que l'activité économique
repart il faut que les gosses
effectivement que les élèves soient
gardés qu'il soit dans les écoles dans
les collèges et et dans les lycées et si
on fait des comparatifs européen alors
il faut tout dire et il faut expliquer
que en allemagne alors en espagne en
italie dans l'état de new york
la rentrée scolaire elle est soit en
septembre soit reportée sine aidiez
c'est-à-dire reportée jusqu'à nouvel
enfant benjamin labbé norvège au
danemark et on allemagne on rouvre avant
un pardonnez moi il faut que l'allemagne
a progressivement pour que ces pays là
sont des pays où l'épidémie a eu une
importance bien moindre qu'en france par
contre en a en espagne en italie dans
l'état de new york c'est à dire dans les
principaux foyers de l'épidémie
c'est en septembre voilà et saha
incertain se garde bien de le dire
alors après dans les entreprises mais
écoutez je vais vous dire encore une
fois se pose la question de la sécurité
sanitaire
parce que ce qui est valable pour les
profs est valable pour les salariés du
privé
bien évidemment et ça c'est un vrai
problème parce que quand on va dire aux
gens moi je vais vous dire en tant que
sais-je et issus souvent interpellé y
compris par des messages sur les réseaux
sociaux ou par des mails par des coups
de téléphone etc de salariés qui me
disent ben moi dans ma boîte j'ai la
direction qui vient de voir et qui me
dit que j'ai intérêt à le pointer les
quand je leur dis que ya pas de masse
qui me disent ils mais il exige de moi
que je vienne et ils exigent en portent
en eux mêmes des masques et des gants
donc encore une fois la sécurité
sanitaire ça doit être l'alpha et
l'oméga sur cette question là que
l'activité économique reprenne mais
écoutez très bien avec des conditions
sanitaires
on a énormément de cas de salariés qui
ont été contaminés sur leur lieu de
travail
voilà nous on a des cas à la cgt on les
ressent sont les connaît et donc
attention s'il ya une deuxième bague qui
arrive on connaît pas grand chose sur
cette épidémie on marche comme des
aveugles et on tâtonne si elle arrive
et bah qu'est ce qui se passera certains
prendront des airs de pleureuse mais ce
sera trop tard
gouverner c'est anticiper et donc
certains sont en réalité se comportent
comme des apprentis sorciers donc nous
on alerte on dit attention cette maladie
est un fléau c'est une véritable peste
attention la sécurité des gens c'est le
premier des critères 1 philippe herlin
quelle est leur garde l'économiste que
vous êtes sur l'exception suédoise qui
se portent pas spécialement plus mal que
la france au que les autres pays un le
bilan n'est pas brillant mais enfin
c'est pas pire qui a choisi quand même
de sauvegarder l'économie de crainte que
ça fasse finalement entre guillemets eu
plus de morts après ouais mais ce qui
s'est passé en suède c'est que les
règles distanciation sociales ont été
respectées de façon très importante donc
il ya pas eu d'explosion et puis c'est
des pays où comme en allemagne ou de
pays du nord
il ya eu des tests nombreux et une prise
en charge par la période par l'opie par
les appareils de santé et rapide ce qui
n'est pas le cas de la france que le
problème de la france c'est qu'on n'a
pas assez de basques et moi je mettrai
ça aussi sur le dos d'un certain un
étatisme français parce qu'il faut
savoir qu'aujourd'hui il ya encore des
douanes qui le montrent que si vous
voulez apporter plus de 5 millions de
masques en france vous pouvez faire
l'objet d'une réquisition on décourage
les entreprises ou les vendeurs
n'importe qui d'apporter une masque pour
risque de se faire à conditionner quoi
il ya beaucoup de pharmaciens qui
pourrait vendre qui pourrait acheter un
porter des masques et les vendre au
public et qu'ils ne le croient aux gens
parce que les tables mardi on est dans
un modèle étatiste et dirigiste en
france moi je considère que pour qu'on
puisse avoir des tests et des masques il
faudrait libéraliser le secteur c'est là
qu'il faut permettre à n'importe qui
alors en premier aux pharmacies qui qui
qui ont déjà leurs réseaux mais à
n'importe quel aux grandes surfaces
magasins de pouvoir commander des mains
à ce que soient fabriquées ou importées
de l'étranger et de les vendre et de
cette façon là on pourra avoir
suffisamment de masques alors
qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde se repose
sur les méga commande que qu'a fait
l'état et on est obligé de le croire sur
parole le problème c'est que si le 11
mai il ya pas le milliard ou les 2
milliard de masques la question qu'on
peut se poser
vu de l'extérieur c'est peut-être pour
les travaillistes et c'est peut-être
plus compliqué que ça enfin l'une des
clés du succès allemand
c'est d'avoir réquisitionné plusieurs
usines et d'avoir pour la fabriquer des
masques en nombre alors c'est vrai
pourquoi on l'a pas fait peut-être que
vous le savez mieux que moi mais en
l'occurrence moi je me porte en faux
vous avez dit vampire monsieur-là
correspond à une petite musique qu'on
entend ces derniers temps certains ont
effectivement le comment dire
l'inventivité de pod comment dire de 2 2
m dans le box des accusés
le soi-disant étatisme ou le trop grand
poids de l'administration
mais attendez sur cette histoire de
masques c'est très simple quel
responsable si ce n'est effectivement le
libéralisme
qu'est ce que c'est qu'ils sont les
responsables si ce nom si ce n'est
effectivement les délocalisations qui
ont été commandés reporter je dirais aux
au pinacle par certains certains ont
fait de la délocalisation une sorte de
fantôme un une fatalité
alors qu'en réalité effectivement
d'autres pays ont conservé leur
patrimoine industriel ont refusé de le
brader et sont en capacité de produire
des masques la france est la sixième
puissance économique mondiale est les
grands principes à une des principales
nations économique
mais le roi est nu puisque nous sommes
un foutu de produire des masques et et
que nous avons sur ce secteur-là mais
comme sur d'autres brader notre
patrimoine industriel
je vais vous dire lors le jour d'après
je lis j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le
dire mais j'aime le marteler le jour
d'après doit être celui dans lequel nous
mettons effectivement la mondialisation
dans le box des accusés
cette crise cette crise du coc vide 19 à
tous les égards est une crise de la
civilisation libérale un philippe herlin
là la réponse non mais et il faut être
sérieux c'est pas l'ultra libéralisme
est la cause de ça la france c'est le
pays le cd le cas le taux auquel le taux
de prélèvements obligatoires le plus
élevé donc ça décourage la production en
france donc la meilleure façon de faire
revenir la production en france
c'est de diminuer le niveau des taxes et
des impôts et sans me radieux faire
depuis longtemps
c'est aussi de lutter contre l'esprit
normatif et bureaucratique dont la
france est une des championnes du monde
et puis c'est aussi d'avoir des
syndicats qui sont plus responsables en
allemagne les syndicats disque
en france la cgt fait grève pour pour un
non on le voit parlement pour les
dockers et où il ya des pertes d'emploi
où la plupart du trafic se fait la gêne
ou dans d'autres ou dans d'autres ports
et le et tout l'est et tous les ports
français perdent de perdre de l'acidité
et sa soeur sara tente et surtout le
secteur économique
doc stoxx donc celle ci voit là qu'il
faut agir c'est une baisse des impôts
une baisse de la bureaucratie une baisse
des normes et un dialogue social qui
soit facilitée par rapport à aujourd'hui
voilà c'est à ces conditions là qu'on
pourra faire revenir les usines en
france
et effectivement c'est un objectif que
l'on doit se fixer dès la sortie du
confinement pour avoir une reprise la
plus vigoureuse possible merci à tous
les deux on vous ne mettra pas d'accord
ce soir benjamin amara merci philippe
herlin d'avoir été avec nous pour ce
face à face persia vous et autre
conséquence de cette épidémie la
consommation de viande bovine augmente
dans les ménages
les gens confinés chez eux font
davantage la cuisine mais là où ça
coince et que les prix payés aux
éleveurs continuent à s'effondrer alors
qu'ils ont augmenté curieusement dans
les rayons une situation intenable pour
plusieurs syndicats agricoles qui ont
décidé de lancer un appel commun aux
éleveurs il leur demande de garder leurs
animaux à la ferme et de ne pas les
vendre tant que la grande distribution
et les amateurs ne leur proposeront pas
un prix correct et pour en parler nous
sommes avec denis perrault secrétaire
national de la confédération paysanne
bonsoir denis perreault on rappelle ce
chiffre un bonsoir et merci surtout
d'être avec nous rappelle ce chiffre aux
de la consommation de la viande 18% ça
aurait pu être une excellente nouvelle
pour vous mais ça ne l'est pas vraiment
on imagine votre déception oui bonsoir
lui évidemment on est forcément déçu
vous constaterez et non seulement 2
le marché monte mais les prix à la
consommation augmente aussi
et pour les paroles et les industries
les marchands les amateurs continuent de
faire pression sur les prix relativement
bas depuis quelques années est bien en
dessous des coûts de production donc on
a décidé de s'associer à la fédération
nationale bovine sur ce sujet là pour
faire de la rétention pour obliger le
gouvernement à s'impliquer dans ces
dossiers là et à tordre le bras ou aux
industriels pour une meilleure
répartition de la marge et pour qu'on
arrive à un prix rémunérateur justement
denis perron avant d'aller plus loin
c'est important pour les téléspectateurs
qui nous regardent
effectivement on a tous sincèrement je
le dis franchement sur ce plateau
constater ces hausses de prix dans les
supermarchés
vous vous dites voilà qu'on n'est pas
vous n'êtes pas payé en fonction où va
l'argent est une bonne question
les prix sont un peu discuté on à faire
trop sauf et sur le steak haché où là
c'est le flic égal que ce soit sur les
prix et quantités et tout ça est
manifestement c'est sur ces tapis pour
le reste les plus parce que l'on survolé
on doit être à +61 framerate patrice 38
ou quelque chose comme ça et c'est
vraiment sur le steak haché qui a priori
le pelage de d'obscurantisme d'obscurité
tout au moins sur les la répartition des
marges
donc on va nous dire qu'il ya quelques
problèmes de logistique
effectivement il ya peut-être un peu
moins de camions il ya un peu moins de
monde à battre lorsqu'il ya des salariés
qui gardent leurs gamins où ils font
valoir leur droit de retrait mais
globalement on
on se demande où passe l'argent donc
vous vous adaptez clairement au
gouvernement pour qu'il fasse pression
est ce que le gouvernement réellement
une marge de manoeuvre on a il ya deux
ans soit on
il ya eu les états généraux de
l'agriculture dont le but de la
manoeuvre était de répartir la marge est
de trouver les prix de revient les coûts
de production et tout ça pour que la
marge et russie inde chine et
d'agriculteurs l'état des courses les
coupes production bien été calculé mais
au lieu de fixer les primes d'imposer
quelques jongles le gouvernement a dit
ça serait bien de répartir la valeur un
petit peu plus équitablement
donc vous comprenez bien que sur une
simple suggestion
il n'y a pas de bon coeur et n'y va pas
naturellement
merci beaucoup en tout cas denis
perrault secrétaire national
confédération paysanne de vous être
exprimé en direct sur rt france on en
vient à la situation de cette crise en
europe plusieurs pays entame le
processus de déconfinement c'est le cas
de la norvège et de l'allemagne
outre-rhin les magasins de moins de 800
mètres carrés ont pu rouvrir leurs
portes aujourd'hui avec 135 mille cas
recensé environ 4000 décès dans le pays
l'épidémie de kobe 19
il serait sous contrôle et gérable selon
les autorités l allemagne qui bénéficie
également de quarante mille lits
animations le pays n'a pas hésité à
rapidement des pistes et massivement la
population
angela merkel qui demande tout de même à
ses citoyens de la discipline dans la
lutte encore longue
contre l'épidémie mme ndéye est en cours
au film s'il nous levons les
restrictions maintenant si nous les a
soufflé son cas alors nous ne savons pas
exactement quelles seront les
conséquences et nous devons de procéder
progressivement lentement et prudemment
stiftung des symptômes c'est cool c'est
pourquoi nous ne devons pas devenir
négligent et frivole une seconde
dauphine strain c'est à cannes
nous ne pouvons pas nous permettre
l'insécurité même pour une seconde
il est très important de ne plus être
négligents tenons compte des quarts et
ping restons vigilants et discipliné et
quand je dis nous je veux dire tout le
monde les citoyens de ce pays
tu as à leurs fibres grenoble 2 1 les
allemands qui sont plutôt heureux de
voir le pays en voie de déconfinement
même s'il faut rester très prudent
d'effroi c'est agréable de voir les
magasins ouverts année en dehors de ça
il n'y a pas vraiment de changement
presque tout le monde porte déjà un
masque facial et la plupart s'y tiennent
il a été dit que ce n'est pas de
l'autoprotection mais de la protection
des autres dans les transports en commun
je trouve acceptable de porter un masque
car vous êtes assis et plus près les uns
les autres
mais dans les magasins je pense que vous
pouvez trouver une solution différente
la vie doit revenir lentement lentement
à la normalité car les contacts sociaux
et la vie sociale en général se perdent
est le bilan du cornât virus en espagne
et passer nuit sous la barre des 400
morts aujourd'hui pour la première fois
en un mois le kobe 19 et 399 décès dans
le pays en 24 heures la baisse du nombre
de morts mais aussi d'hospitalisation à
soulager le système de santé espagnol
déborder pendant plusieurs semaines au
total plus de 20 mille huit cent
cinquante personnes ont succombé à la
maladie en espagne le troisième pays le
plus endeuillé par la pandémie après les
états unis et l'italie et pour parler
nous sommes en direct avec roanne
ambrosio ni médecin spécialiste des
maladies infectieuses bonsoir monsieur
renaud ambrosia ni merci d'être avec
nous le bilan quotidien qui passe sous
la barre dont des 400 décès on imagine
que le médecin vous êtes doute que vous
êtes reste prudent oui on reste
l'épreuve en fait moi même je suis
médecin et patient en même temps parce
que moi j'ai fini par lui injecter mais
c'est vrai que depuis quelques semaines
on maquille amende de pression sur le
système de santé
l'espagne à moins de cas confirmés il ya
un monde d'écart qui sont admis aux
soins intensifs mais en reste et les
plus grands parce qu'on sécurise aussi
la mesure combat un peu commencé avec
les arènes accepté les mesures de
confinement de la population
on pourrait avoir une deuxième bague
donc il faut rester très prudent
oui c'est ce que j'allais vous dire
parce qu'effectivement cette baisse à
aller plutôt général à toute l'europe en
même temps c'est logique nous sommes
tous confinés est ce que c'est une vraie
inquiétude pour vous médecin atteint
vous l'avez dit du coc vide 19 qu'est ce
qui va se passer
la clé maintenant elle est plutôt
politique dans la gestion se
déconfinement vous en attendait beaucoup
des autorités alors cynique et de
réelles effectivement parce qu'on ne
sait pas si tu vas s'est passé avec cd
confinement il ya beaucoup de
spéculations aussi sur le fait qu'il ya
beaucoup de monde que les puisse
affecter de façon asymptomatique ou très
peu symptomatiques et que l'épisode
développer une immunité donc qui serait
au moins partiellement protégés mais
c'est vrai que là on a dream un moment
il faut faire un bilan de la situation
politique et la situation sanitaire
il en espère qu'en se trompent pas et
qui voit là une certaine qu'il voudrait
population protégée et que la panne de
simbad si puissante que c'est qu'on a eu
tout à l'heure on sait que le
confinement est très stricte en espagne
notamment pour les enfants qui n'avaient
même pas le droit de prendre l'air on
imagine le désarroi des pauvres parents
espagnols
comment les choses
vont évoluer justement quelle est la
stratégie du gouvernement vu de
déconfinement qui a commencé un an
certaines industries
alors heureusement je vais pas d'enfants
à la maison nous avons été beaucoup plus
difficile d'être malin avec des chansons
je pense que c'est une vraie nécessité
de relaxer un peu la situation pour les
gens c'est beaucoup de semaines
maintenant et on espère que ça aura des
conséquences négatives
on sait recycler les enfants font des
passes ntation cliniques très léger mais
ce qui fait peur c'est qu'il puisse
acteurs comme des transmissions pour
d'autres personnes installées çà va
prêter la situation c'était vraiment une
nécessité et qu'on m'en sers et l'accès
à ces situations sociales tellement
difficile depuis des semaines
en espagne on parle évidemment j'imagine
en espagne aussi forcément des tests des
masques il ya une pénurie en france est
ce que c'est le cas également en espagne
je connais pas la situation dans tous
les pays mais en tout cas c'était pas
les canes allemand l'institution et a
versé 90 général on n'a pas eu cette
pénurie mais ça vaut le coup on a
entendu d'autres parties du pays
ça c'est juste une question peut-être
plus personnel vous vous en avez parlé
vous même vous avez donc fini par
contracté cette maladie due qu'aux vie
de 19 commentaires et vous comment on
peut se soigner
est-ce que ça a été difficile cette
période est ce que ça dure expliquez
nous alors merci beaucoup de votre
question alors heureusement je n'ai pas
une forme très très grave
en fait la plupart le 80% des cas font
des ponts très légers de la maladie
c'est à partir de la deuxième semaine
parfois on développe des c'est qu'on
appelle un 1 1
saito kingston il ya des personnes qui
font une forme beaucoup plus là des
maladies haut niveau pour le maire
heureusement c'était pas mon cas mais
j'avais des myalgies dynastie ni une
fatigue stress important est le fait de
connaître les complications que peut
faire c'était aussi difficile mais
heureusement ce n'était pas le cas mais
évidemment on pourrait aussi rester à
l'hôpital pour nos collègues on
entendait notre médecin français en
ouverture jérôme marty dire que selon
lui le bilan des victimes était vraiment
mais vraiment sous-estimer ce que c'est
votre avis aussi de médecins c'est très
difficile à dire mais savait lacker la
statistique un peu plus précis en tête
le talent je pense que c'est possible et
qu'il me dise estimations effectivement
merci beaucoup au roi non roi ni d'avoir
été avec nos médecins spécialistes des
maladies infectueuses
on direct d'espagne donc alors que la
moitié de la population mondiale est
cloîtrée chez elle pour éviter la
propagation du comique 19 les mouvements
qui confinement se multiplient donc à
travers le globe un sujet d'alexis
combat avec cécilia chaumont les mesures
de confinement sont est liberticide
aux etats unis pays le plus durement
touché par la pandémie avec 48 morts
beaucoup n'hésitent pas à braver les
interdits pour protester contre le
confinement notamment virginie ou dans
le colorado
s'ils sont critiqués par une bonne
partie de l'opinion publique
ces mouvements de contestation ont reçu
le soutien de donald trump
sur twitter le président des états unis
a même appelé les manifestants à libérer
ses états et on a profité pour tacler
ses adversaires démocrates ces gens
expriment leur point de vue
je vois où ils sont et ce qu'ils sont en
train de faire des films de bus ont
l'air de personnes tout à fait
responsable libérer le minnesota libérer
le michigan libérer la virginie sauver
notre cher deuxième amendement il est
assiégé
mais ces américains ne sont pas les
seuls à remettre en cause la politique
de leur pays vis-à-vis de la crise
sanitaire
à l'image de l'allemagne alors que le
confinement a récemment été prolongé
jusqu'au 3 mai les différentes mesures
mises en place par angela merkel font
craindre une atteinte aux droits
fondamentaux garantis par la
constitution
[Musique]
je suis ici pour manifester pour mes
droits fondamentaux garantis par la
constitution
lorsqu'un droit n'est plus applicable et
que l'on ne peut pas lutter contre
l'injustice nous descendons dans la rue
en israël c'est le premier ministre
benyamin nétanyahou qui est dans le
viseur de ses opposants qui étaient au
nombre de 2000 à montrer leur
désapprobation ce week end à tel aviv
ses adversaires l'accusent d'avoir
profité de la crise du coronavirus pour
échapper à la justice now one person
indjic aubenas ne nous enlèvera sûr
comme une croix ue personne ne trouve à
10 humide échappatoire en changeant le
fonctionnement de notre parlons en
changeant le coeur battant de cette
admirable et commentent nation au brésil
le président gère ball sur la roue
continue de minimiser la gravité de la
crise sanitaire
depuis quelques jours un mouvement
politique d'extrême droite qui entend
sauver l'économie du pays
au courage les brésiliens manifesté dans
les rues de sao paulo contre les mesures
de confinement
ils sont
[Musique]
des villes audoises il n'y a aucun
cadeau for maggi russie ce qui concerne
près de 80% des villes du brésil
alors arrêtez mettre à l'arrêt du pays
des responsables
si les enjeux diffèrent selon les pays
pour justifier ce refus de rester chez
soi les manifestants qui confinement se
font de plus en plus entendre quitte à
choquer ou a contrario créer un effet
boule de neige
en russie le président vladimir poutine
a organisé une réunion sur le
coronavirus avec ses ministres en
visioconférence selon président russe le
pig coronavirus en russie reste à venir
il peut être ralenti mais il est
impossible de l'arrêter continue-t-il
l'épidémie du coït 19 progresse
fortement dans le pays six mille
soixante nouveaux cas ont été déclarés
ce dimanche une urgence qui n'échappe
pas au kremlin ont fait le point à
moscou avec à notre correspondant sur
place antoine claireaux plusieurs
chiffres
la vice-premier ministre en charge du
dossier a commencé par annoncer les
derniers chiffres plus de quarante sept
mille personnes sont infectées avec une
hausse de 10 % de nouveaux cas ces
dernières 24 heures ont la main pour un
bilan humain à l'heure actuelle qui
s'élève à 4 105 morts ensuite mis
l'accent sur les efforts fournis en
russie sur le dépistage de la maladie en
effet en date d'aujourd'hui plus de 2
millions de tests ont été effectués
actuellement le deuxième pays le plus
testé au monde
en agissant de la sorte c'est à dire en
multipliant les tester en identifiant
les malades qui n'ont pas de symptômes
les autorités sanitaires espère
combattre plus efficacement la
propagation de la maladie
du côté de la prévention et de la
protection vladimir poutine a fait
savoir que la production quotidienne de
masques en russie allait prochainement
passer de 3,5 à 7 millions sans parler
des masques importés depuis la chine en
particulier car le plus dur reste encore
à venir
je vous propose de l'écouter nous
arrivons à maintenir
l'objectif de la première étape de
diffusion c'est à dire de freiner cette
évolution mais il ne faut pas s'arrêter
là
comme le disent les spécialistes vous et
vos collègues
le pic de l'épidémie est encore à venir
et nous devons faire le maximum pour
simplifier tout ça toute cette situation
il limiter le nombre de nouvelles de
nouveaux malades et ne travaillant sur
dans toutes les directions là dessus
mais à partir de la semaine prochaine un
fonds spécialisé dédié pour de lits
d'hôpitaux spécialisées supplémentaires
va être affectée et je le répète ici
tous les scénarios possibles doivent
être ambiant visage est toujours durant
cette réunion de travail vladimir
poutine a demandé aux experts les
différentes projections de l'évolution
de la maladie à plusieurs échéances à 3
7 10 30 jours afin de mettre à jour et
prendre en considération tous les
scénarios possibles
il a aussi tenu à rappeler que les
mesures de confinement et de semaine de
travail chômé depuis le début du mois
d'avril avait permis de gagner du temps
et surtout de ne pas reconnaître une
hausse brutale de nouveaux cas et
conséquence directe est positif du
confinement la qualité de l'air
s'améliore en un mois les concentrations
de dioxyde d azote ont reculé de moitié
dans les grandes capitales européennes
on voit ça avec cécilia chaumont
paris désert respire mieux du 13 mars au
13 avril le satellite copernicus
sentinelle 5 p a observé la france mais
aussi l'espagne et le nord de l'italie
pour l'agencé spatiale européenne
comparé aux données du mois de mars de
l'année dernière et grâce aux travaux de
l'institut météorologique royale des
pays bas
ces images révèlent une impressionnante
baisse de la pollution atmosphérique
-48% de dioxyde d'azoté à madrid avec
15% de marge d'erreur la baisse est à
peu près équivalente à milan et à rome
quant à paris la diminution atteint même
50 4% à l'origine de cette amélioration
la réduction du trafic routier bien sûr
mais pas seulement
avec la baisse des activités économiques
et industriels le satellite observe une
baisse de la combustion d'énergies
fossiles
mercredi 1er avril le secrétaire général
de l'onu a estimé que la terre vivaient
je cite sa pire crise mondiale depuis
que l'onu a été fondée il ya 75 ans l'
agence spatiale européenne veut aussi
sensibiliser la population pour tirer
les leçons de cette expérience
selon le dernier rapport de l'agencé
européenne de l'environnement sur la
qualité de l'air de 2019
le dioxyde d'azoté est responsable de
68000 décès prématurés par rendant lieu
dont 7500 en france l'or noir s'effondre
sur les marchés mondiaux le baril de
pétrole américain est tombé aujourd'hui
sous le seuil des 0 $ concrètement cela
veut dire que les producteurs pays pour
donner à leurs marines de pétrole à
niveau jamais atteint dans l'histoire au
sein
un marché anéantie par une demande en
chute libre et des réserves s'approchant
de la saturation aux états unis restez
avec nous donc quelques instants notre
édition de 21h la suite de l'émission
nous reviendrons sur la crise lui
coronavirus en france notamment la barre
des 20000 décès a été franchi depuis le
début de l'épidémie
quant aux des compliments des précisions
sur la stratégie sont attendus dans les
15 jours puis nous parlerons à des
violences de plus en plus nombreuses à
l'encontre des policiers dans certains
quartiers
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française d'autres affirment
même que nous ne sommes pas journalistes
mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
l'écologie ce n'est pas de la politique
des rapports du giec sur les océans
comme ça fout les jetons
on est dans une espèce de déni collectif
on ne veut pas croire ce qu'on sait et
scientifique parle quand même de la
sixième extinction de la vie sur terre
sixième extinction la vie sur terre il
ya d'autres experts qui contestent leur
donne aux personnes non non c'est pas
vrai il ya des climats tous et non ce
n'est pas rien à part il ya des gens qui
ne sont pas des chercheurs qui parlent
que la presse met en avant parce que il
faut que du débat il ya plus de débat
aujourd'hui
y a plus aucun débat ce changement
climatique et on va vers une vraie marée
de catastrophe va vers une vraie
catastrophe et on est incapable d'en
prendre conscience
mais ce n'est pas de taissy mist tout
comprendre ce qui va arriver pour moi je
pense qu'on est comme une guerre
aujourd'hui on est entré en guerre
contre nos façons de vue et les demis y
en a pas des demies l'ennemi ceni
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
[Musique]
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
alors ceux qui six interdit d'interdire
nous allons évoquer ici des sujets
stratégiques pour notre pays et sur ces
dossiers sensibles
je vais partager avec vous mon
interprétation quelle que soit la
qualité expertise indéniable de nos
soldats
ils ne peuvent gagner la guerre pour la
raison que je vais battre
que peuvent faire un peu plus de 5000
militaires français à l'efficacité
certes reconnu sur une zone aussi vaste
même renforcé par cinq mille soldats
pour lui par les pays eux cinq salles
c'est là où les problèmes ont commencé
les déclarations récentes des politiques
des spécialistes des experts des
militaires montre bien que nous sommes
face à une incompréhension totale entre
les différents acteurs
si la france n'a pas la volonté
nécessaire pour assurer la réalisation
de ses objectifs et de les accompagner
par qu'il ne s'agit pas d'imposer il
s'agit de convaincre et d'accompagner il
est à craindre que nous terminions
enlisé dans un conflit sans fin
[Musique]
cette crise qui n'est pas je vous
rappelle qu'une crise de santé publique
c'est malheureusement devenu une crise
économique majeure
tous les pays européens se sont repliés
sur eux mêmes et ont joué leur carte
sans s'occuper de ce qui se passait
ailleurs est ce qui veut dire que les
états gardent donc ait la main-mise sur
leur politique de santé est ce qu'il
faudrait peut-être revoir un peu hâlé
statut il faudrait que les états aient
réellement la main aujourd'hui on règle
à nouveau un problème économique par de
la dette
ça vous aliens ça vous ça donne les clés
de chez vous soit aux banquiers soit
l'état maintenant il n'ya pas il ya même
plus débat
on sait que l'union européenne est mort
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre pour
cette demi heure d'information il est
21h heure de paris tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité les conditions
d'un déconfinement partir du 11 mai sont
elles réunies les incertitudes des
questions demeurent au lendemain de la
conférence de presse edouard philippe
il s'agit du début d'une nouvelle phase
avec des précautions sanitaires toujours
de mise et à respecter pendant plusieurs
mois dans le pays
la tension ne redescend pas du côté de
villeneuve la garenne dans les hauts de
seine des échauffourées ont à nouveau
éclaté la nuit dernière quatre individus
ont été interpellés a sonné après
l'accident de moto impliquant une
voiture de police
deux versions s'opposent aujourd'hui
entre forces de l'ordre et témoins dans
la nuit plusieurs autres communes de la
région ont connu des heures
[Musique]
la france franchit donc un cap
symbolique et douloureux et déplore plus
de vingt mille décès liés aux
coronavirus annonce du directeur général
de la santé jérôme sainement en début de
soirée qui explique que chaque personne
tout de même malade contamine moins
d'une personne autour d'elle contre
trois au début de l'épidémie ce qui veut
dire que la phase de freinage est bien
entamé le nombre de décès à l'hôpital
est de 547 en 24 heures et hier edouard
philippe a donc présenté aux côtés du
ministre de la santé les grandes lignes
du plan de déconfinement qui sera
appliquée à partir du 11 mai pas de
grande annonce mais le quotidien sera
différent selon lui le point avec
l'édito de nadège abderrazak beaucoup de
questions pour très peu de réponses
assurer le service après-vente de
l'allocution présidentielle s'est avérée
compliquée pour edouard philippe est le
premier ministre le reconnaît lui même
évidemment beaucoup d'entre vous
s'interrogent sur ce qui va se passer au
moment du décompte final sur la façon
dont la vie va reprendre une fois le
confinement levées sur la façon dont
nous allons pouvoir recommencer à
travailler à nous déplacer à voyager à
étudier à faire du sport à retrouver nos
amis nos proches bref sur la façon dont
nous allons pouvoir recommencer à vivre
librement
ces questions elles sont légitimes je
sais que beaucoup de ceux qui nous
regardent aimerait que j'entre dans le
détail de ce qui va se passer
le 11 mai et dans les jours les semaines
et les mois qui suivront je ne répondrai
pas à toutes ces questions aujourd'hui
le chef du gouvernement s'est livrée ici
à ce qu'il qualifie lui-même d'exercice
de clarté de transparence sur la
situation actuelle et il le dit il
faudra vivre avec le virus
pas de vaccin avant 2021 pas de
traitement efficace ou connus mais d'ici
là les mêmes recommandations le respect
des gestes barrières
la multiplication des tests la mise à
l'isolément des personnes malades
edouard philippe met en garde la vie
d'avant ne sera plus la même à partir du
11 mai la france connaîtra en 2020 sa
pire récession depuis 1945
d'où peut-être l'importance de la
réouverture des écoles le 11 mai mais
pour le gouvernement il s'agit d'abord
de lutter contre les inégalités sociales
et scolaires les écoles n'ouvriront pas
partout le 11 mai et ne fonctionnera pas
partout le 11 mai dans les conditions
dans lesquelles elle fonctionnait le 11
février
mais nous devons commencer à ouvrir les
écoles pour une raison très simple
aujourd'hui beaucoup de professeurs font
un travail remarquable
ils font en sorte que le lien entre
l'élève et le professeur qui est
évidemment d'une nature très différente
en période de confinement et parfois
d'une nature un peu insatisfaisante soit
maintenu que le travail d'acquisition de
réflexion j'allais dire d'élévation même
des élèves puissent se poursuivre mais
un certain nombre d'élèves n'ont pas
accès à ces instruments se retrouve dans
une situation où le lien avec l'école
est rompu
cette situation est une situation qui
présente pour la nation c'est un grave
danger rouvrir les écoles c'est d'accord
mais pas les restaurants les bars et les
cinémas une incohérence dénoncée
notamment par de nombreux enseignants et
parents d'élèves mais salué en revanche
par le medef
nous sommes satisfaits que le président
ait fixé un cap pour remettre le pays en
marche
cela permet aux entreprises de bien
préparer la reprise et aux enfants de
retrouver le chemin de l'école
seule révélation peut être lors de cette
double conférence de presse celle
d'olivier ferrand les portes des ehpad
rouvre pour les proches des
pensionnaires pas de rapprochement
physique mais un contact visuel
uniquement ce serait à la demande du
résident ce sera dans des conditions
extrêmement vous l'imaginez
limitez pas plus de deux personnes de la
famille pas tout le monde en même temps
ce sera sous la responsabilité des
directions encore une fois
d'établissement qui devront dire à la
famille lorsque ce sera possible et dans
quelles conditions
sachant que la sécurité sanitaire
reste au coeur de notre projet et qu'il
y aura donc l'impossibilité maintenu
d'aller toucher la personne d'être en
contact physique par contre il y aura un
contact visuel on peut passer beaucoup
de choses avec le regard auprès des
personnes qu'on aime et j'imagine le
soulagement qui sera celui des nombreux
et dans des nombreuses familles quand
ils pourront à nouveau rendre visite à
leurs proches souvent des personnes en
perte d'autonomie parfois désorientés
mais qui savent très bien ce que c'est
que la valeur d'un regard d'une personne
aimante
qu'il s'agisse de l'utilité des masques
du confinement prolongée des personnes
âgées
le gouvernement multiplie les rétro
pédalage une situation qui renforce
l'idée qu'ils naviguent à vue dans la
gestion de cette crise ducobu de 19 et
pour en parler nous sommes avec arnaud
benedetti rédacteur en chef de la revue
politique et parlementaire bonsoir
arnaud benedetti et alors on a vu qu
emmanuel macron avait redorée un petit
peu son blason au niveau de la confiance
lors de son dernier discours cette
conférence de presse d'edouard philippe
est ce qu'elle est et est de nature
selon vous à redonner confiance aux
français et à rassurer ou alors rajouter
plutôt de la confusion
s'ils voulaient c'était une conférence
de presse qu'il ressemblait plutôt un
rapport d'étape où le premier ministre
est venu comme l'a rappelé votre
éditorialistes faire le service après
vente du président de la république
après son allocution de lundi dernier on
avait un premier ministre qui à force de
powerpoint le diagramme deux chiffres
s'est efforcé d'oeuvrer contextualiser
la situation de donner quelques signes
d'espoir en expliquant siffrein appui
que la tension sur l'offre de soins et
est aujourd'hui lé moindre même si elle
restait forte qu'elle ne l'avait été il
ya encore quelques jours mais finalement
cette conférence de presse a répondu à
très peu de questions concernant
notamment l'objectif qu'a fixé président
de la république c'est-à-dire l'objectif
de sortie progressive du confinement à
partir du
mais on reste aujourd'hui avec plusieurs
angles morts concernant les moyens
sanitaires c'est à dire les masques
concernant les tests concernant la façon
dont le retour des enfants va
éventuellement s'opérer dans les écoles
sur tous ces sujets on voit bien que on
est disons dans une opération de work in
progress c'est à dire que on apprend en
marchant mais les solutions concrètes ne
sont pas encore en tout cas apparu on a
justement le sentiment que les français
se posent davantage encore de questions
sur ce déconfinement va-t-il être bien
préparés suffisant est il crédible au 11
mai moins que jamais on a on a la
réponse finalement si vous voulez le
président de la république à annoncer
une date le 11 mai qu'il faut
aujourd'hui absolument tenir ne serait
ce que symboliquement mais une grande
partie de l'opinion et la majorité de
nos compatriotes ont vraisemblablement
compris après avoir entendu le premier
ministre hier même s'il avait récemment
compris lors aussi de la première
allocution du président de la république
et les reprise ensuite de ces différents
ministres suite à cette allocution que
ceux des confinement se faisait de
manière très étroite et très progressive
mais il y a deux éléments qui sont
aujourd'hui extrêmement important pour
l'exécutif en france dans cette crise
qui explique vincent dans cette volonté
de tenir un discours sur le dic de le
déconfinement ce sont d'abord les
paramètres économiques car on sait que
aujourd'hui la situation économique et
la situation sociale suite à cette crise
sanitaire sera pour le moins tendues et
puis il ya aussi la comparaison que l'on
fait avec un certain nombre d'états
voisins qui ont donné le sentiment et
pas seulement donné le sentiment est que
les sens mieux maîtriser la propagation
de l'épidémie et qui ont déjà opéré une
première étape dans le déconfinement
qu'il s'agisse par exemple
houde et les autrichiens comment
explique-t-on comment expliquez vous ce
manque d'anticipation de la part du
gouvernement français alors que vous le
soulignez les voisins européens semblent
mieux parer à cette situation à
commencer par le voisin allemand
écoutez je pense que il ya d'abord un
phénomène qui dépasse même le cadre du
seul mandat d' emmanuel macron c'est à
dire que on a connu depuis un certain
nombre d'années voire de décennies un
processus de désarmement sanitaires à
travers des logiques comptables dans
l'hôpital public et au niveau d'un
certain nombre d'opérateurs sanitaires
donc cet exécutif a une part de
responsabilité mais une part de
responsabilité qui sa stricte dans un
mouvement qui est beaucoup plus plus
large
ensuite il ya eu dès le départ une
sous-estimation évidente au delà de la
menace virale je rappelle que la
ministre de la santé madame busin le 24
janvier nous annoncer que ce virus selon
toute vraisemblance avait peu de chances
d'accoster sur les rives de l'europe
donc 7,7 cette faiblesse dans
l'anticipation a vraisemblablement nuit
au bon démarrage de la gestion de crise
aujourd'hui on attend emmanuel macron
évidemment sur le déconfinement mais il
a déjà esquissé la presse jean-yves le
drian dit ma crainte c'est que le monde
d'après ressemble au monde d'avant mais
en pire vous partager cette inquiétude
de jean yves le drian
je crois que en tout cas le président de
la république est soumis à la remise en
question de ce qu'a été sa promesse
politique en 2017 ce qui a été
d'ailleurs l'exercice de son mandat
depuis 2010 est c'est à dire cette idée
que il fallait d'une certaine manière à
marche forcée adapter le pays au
standard
une globalisation à laquelle il ne
s'était pas adaptées depuis finalement
de longues décennies
la crise que nous traversons l'épreuve
sanitaires que nous traversons refait
apparaître un certain nombre de notions
qui étaient des notions qu'ils n'étaient
plus en tout cas porté par les élites
dirigeantes de ce pays il s'agit de la
question de la frontière la question de
la souveraineté la question du contrôle
la question du maîtrise de la maîtrise
et le lacombe s électorale d'emmanuel
macro la promesse politique d' emmanuel
macron est profondément aujourd'hui
collisionner par cette épreuve qui amène
in fine et l'ensemble des dirigeants
occidentaux à se re poser la question
sur leur propre modèle économique
merci beaucoup arnaud benedetti
rédacteur en chef de la revue politique
et parlementaire d'avoir été avec nous
et plus de 16 mille kilomètres de la
métropole la nouvelle calédonie est l'un
des territoires français les moins
touchés par l'eau coronavirus avec
seulement 18 cas de kobe de 19
l'archipel a amorcé aujourd'hui sont des
confinement et mesure qui nécessite une
nouvelle manière de s'organiser tout en
respectant les gestes barrière ans que
j'ai signé pierre jan marier avec
imagine production entreprises commerces
restaurants à nouveau ouvert à nouméa
la vie commence à reprendre son cours
normal le territoire à mort ce sont des
confinement une satisfaction pour les
restaurateurs qui doivent tout de même
adapter leur façon de travailler
on a donc prévu de commandes hier de
fait les clients s'assoient les services
pas d'une table entre chaque
entre chaque client ce qui fait à peu
près de mettre des espaces on a prévu
également de servir avec nos gants avec
nos masques et on a également dû gel
hydroalcoolique que les clients métro
quand ils arrivent au sein de
l'établissement
voilà et on cuisine on a effectivement
prévu d'avoir le moal des changes
possible avec la clientèle avec
seulement 18 cas de coronavirus recensés
et l'absence de nouvelles contaminations
depuis le 4 avril
les autorités de l'archipel du pacifique
ont donc annoncé cette levée progressive
du confinement
elle concernera dès mercredi les
établissements scolaires situés dans la
province sud de l'île salle de classe
désinfecter distribution de gel hydro
alcoolique au lycée do kamo tout est
déjà prêt pour l'arrivée d'une partie
des élèves n'auront que la moitié de
l'effectif c'est à dire que chaque
classe a été divisé en deux groupes
nous mettons en place tout ce qui est
mesure de distanciation dont dans les
classes les élèves seront uniquement à
un parent par tap de deux élèves pareil
aussi dans la cour de récréation où nous
allons veiller à ce qu'il n'y ait aucun
vrai rassemblement des consignes
strictes
pourtant la rentrée des classes ne fait
pas l'unanimité en nouvelle calédonie
les organisations syndicales ainsi que
des membres de la communauté kanak
alerte sur les risques d'un
déconfinement trop hâtif dans la
province indépendantistes au nord de
l'île les établissements ne rouvriront
pas avant le 4 mai la question des la
sécurité sanitaire de nos enfants doit
être doit être complètement garantie
c'est que à l'heure actuelle n'est pas
du tout le cas aussi bien que le risque
zéro n'existe pas mais pour nous il faut
des conditions optimales au niveau
sanitaire pour que nos enfants les
parents n'est pas la boule au ventre en
voyant leurs enfants à la à l'école ils
veulent ouvrir les écoles pour que ce
soit cohérent avec les entreprises aussi
et que les parents autant de travailler
pour ramener l'économie
maintenant nous ce qu'on demande c'est
de laisser les
les secteurs essentiels pour que
l'économie continue de tourner et puis
que les citoyens de la mécanique puisque
continue à avoir leur le revivre ce soit
côté frais toi là on a en a salué les
gens qui devraient continuer à fabriquer
des avis que partage le sénat coutumier
où siègent les représentants des
chefferies traditionnelles kanak
le conseil préconise même un confinement
généralisée jusqu'à la fin du mois
d'avril
et pendant que le pays est confiné la
tension ne redescend pas du côté de
villeneuve la garenne dans les hauts de
seine les échauffourées ont à nouveau
éclaté la nuit dernière une enquête a
été ouverte sur les circonstances de
l'accident de moto et précision avec
david khalifa voitures incendiées feux
d'artifice lancés en direction de la
police tirs de mortier la tension était
toujours présente à villeneuve la
garenne dans la nuit de dimanche à lundi
des actions qui font suite à un grave
accident de moto impliquant la police
samedi soir
une partie des jeunes reproche aux
forces de l'ordre d'en être responsable
la victime aurait percuté à pleine
vitesse la portière ouverte d'une
voiture de police banalisée
grièvement blessé au genou l'homme de 30
ans a été opéré avec succès dans la nuit
de samedi à dimanche les circonstances
autour de l'accident sont encore floues
mais plusieurs habitants affirment que
la portière avait été délibérément
ouverte et parle de bavure policière
de leur côté les policiers assurent eux
avoir mis pied à terre pour procéder au
contrôle du motard qui roulait sans
casque à vive allure sur une moto non
homologuée connu des services de police
et déjà condamné à quatorze reprises
l'individu a annoncé par la voix de son
avocat maître stéphane kass avoir déposé
plainte contre x pour violence aggravée
ils demandent également au parquet de
saisir l'inspection générale de la
police nationale afin d'enquêter sur le
geste du fonctionnaire l'igpn n'a pas
été saisie automatiquement si le parquet
mouline hésite un membre de la famille
se chargera de la saisir mon client dit
qu'il rentrait chez lui que les
policiers n'ont donné aucun signe de
leur présence
il n'avait pas mis le gyrophare il n'ya
donc même pas eu de refus d'obtempérer
autre fait à prendre
en compte selon une source policière du
journal le monde le policier en question
est un commissaire qui a ouvert la
portière
ce qui rend la faire encore plus
délicate à en croire ses mots le parquet
de nanterre de son côté a ouvert une
enquête sur l'ensemble des faits de
l'accident et pourrait vous et pour
évoquer ces incidents de villeneuve la
garenne nous sommes en direct avec nos
âmes
anwar policiers délégué du syndicat
vigie bon soir dans un manoir merci on
se montre avec nous on l'a vu inscrire
ont compliqué c'est le faire parce que
clairement deux versions s'affrontent
votre réaction
alors la réaction c'est la première
c'est un appel au calme à destination
des habitants de villeneuve la garenne
mais également de banlieue le
délassement lieu d'île de france parce
qu'on a eu des échauffourées et des
scènes de violences urbaines la nuit
dernière
l' enquête est en cours donc elle visera
à faire la lumière sur les faits donc il
ya des tentatives de récupération est
évidente en fait de cette affaire il ya
effectivement des gens qui souffle sur
les braises
le soir même des événements à peu près
une demi heure après la diffusion des
images
on a des sites d'extrême droite qui ont
diffusé de fausses images d'émeutes de
en les attribuant à villeneuve la
garenne pour justement provoqué des
violences urbaines
il semblerait malheureusement que la
jeunesse soit tombé dans le panneau et
se soient laissés entraîner dans cette
logique qui vise justement à isoler la
population des banlieues du reste de la
population puisque naturellement période
de confinement est depuis quelques
semaines les banlieues sont caricaturés
comme des zones de non-droit dans
lesquels justement la population ne
respecterait pas le confinement
ce qui est vrai pour une partie d'entre
elles une minorité mais il s'agit pas
d'en faire une généralité et donc
j'invite la jeunesse de toutes ces
villes à respecter le confinement et à
respecter l'appel au calme alors un peu
partout malheureusement sur le
territoire on le constate dans les
quartiers dits sensibles les agressions
contre les forces de l'ordre augmente
c'est une réalité
ces derniers jours justement vous
l'expliquer tout de même par ce contexte
sanitaire très tendues avec plus d'un
mois de confinement et parfois
voilà des complications particulièrement
dans des logements qui ne sont pas
grands
qui ne sont peut-être plus compliqué à
vivre en termes de confinement bien
entendu bien entendu que le confinement
est plus difficile qu'en dira pas
respectée dans ces zones
mais il faut savoir que sur villeneuve
la garenne c'est la population qui a
appelé la police à intervenir ce soir là
et les soirs précédents parce que ce
monsieur qui est très des fables très
défavorablement connu des services de
police et de justice
ça ça donnait justement aux rodéos
urbains de plusieurs soirs est bon il
faut savoir que déjà en journée c'est
extrêmement pénible le bruit d'une
motocyclette non homologuée à ce donc
pour les habitants là on empêche de
confinement il s'était donc la personne
de rouler en moto cross de nuit mais
qu'il faut savoir que la population
était totalement exaspérés et qu'elle a
de bon droit saisi la police pour mettre
fin justement à ces nuisances sonores et
donc effectivement il faut savoir que
c'est un confinement qui ai vécu de
façon extrêmement difficile la mortalité
est la plus importante de france en
seine saint denis alors qu'il s'agit du
département le plus petit en superficie
donc le 92 et juste voisins et notamment
villeneuve la garenne est une ville
voisine du département de la seine saint
denis et donc il faut comprendre
l'exaspération des habitants là je sors
d'un débat avec un adjoint à la mairie
qui disait moi je veux défendre
personnes dans cette affaire
bah si moi je veux défendre l'ensemble
de la population de cette ville qui
demande à vivre calmement paisiblement
et à se débarrasser les nuisances en
tout genre et il se trouve que bon moi
j'entends policiers je fais la
différence entre un jeune qui vit
d'ailleurs ce monsieur n'était pas à
jeun il avait 30 ans mais un jeune qui
vit difficilement confinement qui sort
faire un footing en dehors des horaires
ou quoi que ce soit c'est pas du tout la
même chose que ce qui s'est passé là bas
c'est quelqu'un qui polluaient
l'existence des habitants de plus depuis
plusieurs soirs en roulant sur une moto
cross je veux dire voilà cessé mais
qu'il faut prendre la mesure de ce qui
s'est passé et personne ne peut
aujourd'hui déterminé que le geste de ce
policier était un geste volontaire
personne n'en sait rien rapidement noah
manoir avec le début du ramadan qui doit
commencer en fin de semaine
la quiétude du policier que vous êtes
grandi non vas pas caricaturer parce que
si je vous répondais positivement ça
voudrait insinué que ce sont les
musulmans qui sont susceptibles de
braver les interdits et de causer du
trouble allant public donc moi je ne
veux pas rentrer dans cette façon
d'amalgamé les choses mais effectivement
je pense que c'est une difficulté pour
un certain nombre d'habitants qui va
s'ajouter à tout ce qui est déjà
inhérents au confinement c'est-à-dire
l'affaiblissement la fin puis la
frustration aussi de ne pas pouvoir
pratiquer son culte un dessin de devoir
mais moi j'ai aucun doute sur le fait
que les gens issus de la venue des
musulmanes ont respecté le confinement
vont observer le ramadan comme ils le
pourront et que tout se passera bien
donc je réitère mon appel au calme merci
beaucoup à noah manoir merci d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france et la
tunisie qui prévoit un déconfinement
elle aussi progressif à partir du 3 mai
prochain le chef du gouvernement
tunisien a annoncé hier soir que la
situation était quasiment maîtrisé
confiné depuis le 22 mars à tunisie
recense à l'heure actuelle plus de 800
qu'un et 38 personnes décédées en fait
le point sur place avec notre reporter
ben hassen chébili bonsoir bassin
le gouvernement qui s'est donc prononcé
hier sur la prolongation du confinement
jusqu'au 3 mai date possible dans des
confinement avant de revenir sur les
mesures qu'il entend prendre pour le
mois du ramadan quelles sont ces mesures
effectivement cette famille c'est un
rendez vous qui était très attendue par
le peuple tunisien que le chef du
gouvernement a été passé à la télé donc
interviewés par deux journalistes de la
chaîne nationale il est revenu sur la
situation en tunisie sur les décès dont
38 comme vous l'avez dit avec 879 cas
enregistrés les il a également noté que
43 patients étaient est guéri après
avoir été admis auprès des hôpitaux et
tunisiens présentant bien ce tous les
symptômes du co lead 19 il est revenu
sur ce confinement qui prenait fin hier
il a annoncé qu'il sera prolongé
jusqu'au 3 mai prochain à partir du 4
mai il va y avoir un déconfinement
partiel qui sera organisée donc ce soir
à par secteur par région et surtout par
âge donc le gouvernement reviendra bien
sûr sur les modalités du déconfinement
qui sont prévus pour le 4 mai prochain
il a noté également que les personnes
âgées puis les personnes vulnérables
toute personne malade vais continuer de
respecter ce confinement pour pouvoir
maîtriser et la situation gouvernement a
déclaré que la situation était maîtrisée
par rapport aux voisins du maghreb
l'algérie et le maroc qui enregistre
beaucoup plus de décès beaucoup plus de
personnes contaminées
il est revenu également sur l'appel du
ramadan qui doit s'ouvrir dans un peu
moins d'une semaine donc c'est une
doctrine aux problématiques dans tous
les pays musulmans une problématique
également en france comment vont
s'organiser les musulmans pour pouvoir à
passer ce mois du ramadan le
gouvernement a dit que rien n'allait
changer si ce n'est que l'heure du
couvre-feu qui est à 18 heures à tunis
va passer à 20 heures pour pouvoir
permettre aux tunisiens de de pouvoir
célébrer ce mois saint elle les mosquées
resteront fermées donc pas de prier
collective d'aprilia propre aux maux du
ramadan qui doit se dérouler après la
rupture du jeûne aura là pas lieu il
appelle tous les tunisiens à respecter
ces normes de sécurité et pour pouvoir
bien sûr maîtriser et puis lutter contre
ce qu il a 19 est la même
également annoncé qu'une aide financière
supplémentaire sera attribuée aux
familles les plus démunies pour pouvoir
s'en sortir durant ce mois de ramadhan
et on l'a appris il ya quelques heures
mais c'est mains des tunisiens bloqués
en libye ton dos rejoint la tunisie de
force l'armée étaient déployés à la
frontière entre la tunisie et la libye
effectivement c'est fini c'est un
communiqué du ministère de l'intérieur
et puis beaucoup d' images qui circulent
sur facebook et normand tunisiens sont
bloqués en libye depuis la crise du
coronavirus ils demandent à rejoindre la
tunisie
mais depuis le début du confinement
comme beaucoup de pays dans le monde la
tunisie a fermé ses frontières la libye
est également fermé ses frontières ce
qui était problématique pour ces
tunisiens ces centaines de tunisiens qui
essayaient de rejoindre la tunisie
j'ai appris de source sûre que c'est des
milices qui sont stationnés dans les
frontières entre la libye la tunisie
dans certains points c'est midi cela
aurait ouvert les portes de la libye
pourrait d'ailleurs permettre d'accéder
à la tunisie donc ça a été un gros
problème pour l'armée pour pouvoir gérer
pour les douaniers pardon pour pouvoir
gérer cet afflux massif de tunisiens
donc l'armée a été appelée en renfort
beaucoup de policiers aussi appelé en
renfort on a compté à peu près plus de
658 selon le ministère de l'intérieur
et d'après les sources que j'ai des
personnes qui sont sur place il serait
beaucoup beaucoup plus nombreux à
vouloir regagner la tunisie le
gouvernement craint que parmi ces
personnes qui veulent regagner la
tunisie il n'y ait des terroristes ou ou
des personnes qui sont dans internet
intentions pendant un match elle pour
entrer en tunisie
vous savez qu'elle s'attelle aux
frontières est très très sensible est un
casse-tête pour le gouvernement tunisien
ont beaucoup de contrôles ont été faits
pour prouver qu'ils sont tunisiens
qu'ils ont des papiers et puis un
passeport aux tunisiens pour pour être
identifiée avant de rentrer dans le pays
et ces personnes là ont été transportés
dans le sud région de tozeur dans un
hôtel pour être confinés durant 14 jours
l'opération est toujours en cours donc
l'armée essaie tant bien que mal de
contrôler cet afflux massif de tunisiens
étudiants qui étaient restés bloqués qui
demandait depuis depuis très longtemps
déjà au gouvernement de pouvoir être
rapatriés en tunisie
merci beaucoup bassem chez billets en
direct de tunisie
ok et c'est la fin de cette émission
vous le savez écourtée en raison de
cette crise du corona à virus on
s'adapte tout comme les autres médias
excellente fin de soirée à tous les
programmes continus sur rt france notre
point complet sur l'actualité ce sera
demain matin à 8 heures du matin
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord ici qu'on invite les plus
compétents pas seulement ceux qui
parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce que si seul interdit d'interdire